et celle ci mais clap
soit on n'est pas un fait toutes les
séquences commence par un petit clapot
je suis extrêmement agacé je suis
tellement horripilé c'est bon oui je je
vais jouir énormément de questions que
je m'étale sélectionnés sur le fait que
ma blouse été rose niveau de l'anus
youtube ne pas trop les trucs dessus
même pas ta gueule mais c'est pas grave
tu vois là je fais le neurone à comment
s'appelle le squelette derrière toi je
vous explique au niveau de la nuit la
mer du nord avec l'autre main il m'a
cassé mais cas sessegnon sinon on est
très fort vous explique au niveau de
l'anus
on est équipés de petits muscles ou au
cou aux épaules
elles sont fort quand même depuis le
début d'août d'un truc c'est de la merde
non mais quand même quand même ils sont
forts parce qu'il de file des bus tout
d'un truc hein tu fais quoi là
est ce que tu veux c'est bon mais pas
deux je veux dire qu'il va pas venir
tout noir est tombé comme un fruit
pourri c'est assez bien sage est belle à
la tête de la poule 1 je jouis clap
ok non et si vous êtes à se bouger
bon on résume il yad'un côté allez
maintenant c'est à moi de bosser je
m'étouffe suffit une question s'est en
fait cracher un nom signifie liassine à
cacouna feu à trois points
le système immunitaire et c'est très bon
pour le système immunitaire
donc continuez à lady la langue dans le
fond les amygdales
hélas hélas bon si vous voulez faire un
bébé c'est vrai que c'est mieux de faire
ça plus tôt tous les deux jours où
j'étais en train de me brûler les doigts
ça n'a aucun sens allez système
immunitaire je m'excuse auprès des
abonnés je vais vous rendre d'argent